you know ever since security breach
launched a few weeks ago people have
been scratching their heads theorizing
and wondering but not really knowing
what they're supposed to be theorizing
or wondering about the newest and quite
frankly the most different game in the
five nights at freddy's series some
might say is even the breath of the wild
of finnaf just kidding that was a little
joke but anyway it has proven to be
quite mysterious or has it actually from
what i can see most of the game answers
questions rather than creates new ones
spoiler alert for the entire video by
the way but take the afton ending for
instance there's really only one
question that's left after we see old
billy afton crawl out of a recharge
station and subsequently be torched a
dozen times and then snatched up by the
blob aka molten freddy and that is oh my
god did william afton survive yet again
but the thing is we probably already
know the answer to that question and
it's most likely yes we'll probably see
him again in the next game as another
something trap but that's beside the
point what i'm trying to say is that the
questions left by the game are either
extremely blatant and thus very hard to
figure out like whether the animatronics
are alive because of being possessed by
souls or because of really good ai or to
the point of this whole video what the
deal is with the retro cds that can only
be found once glam rock freddy has
roxanne's eyes or in other words if you
choose to stay after 6 am for those who
are not familiar with what i'm talking
about there are secret collectibles
invisible to the naked eye in the form
of cds 16 of them in fact these cds
called retro cds can only be played in a
super secret room that can only be
accessed after fully upgrading freddy
with both monty's claws and chica's
voice box what's on these cds you ask
bits of therapy sessions i know it's
exactly what you were expecting now when
listening to these cds you can also see
on the cd player itself the title of
whatever cd is playing which starts with
the number of cd 1 through 16 and then
has either 71 or 46 followed by a
two-digit ascending number at the end
the prevailing theory on how to read
these cd titles is that the first number
is simply the number of the retro cd in
the game but the next two right after
the dash because they are different
numbers yet do not ascend like the final
two numbers are most likely referencing
the client being spoken to in said cd
presumably a client number set by the
therapists themselves client 71 and
client 46 the last two numbers are most
likely different sessions of the
aforementioned clients each happening
after the previous session proven by
their ascending order this also makes
sense because the therapists are
replaced after every few cds and that
aids to the notion that the therapy
sessions take place one after the other
now at this point i have to talk about
what most people are already assuming
regarding the identities of the two
clients which i'm sure you could guess
is one of the hottest topics regarding
the cds most people assume that the two
clients are actually one client just
split into two personalities
how are you feeling today and since we
know that client 71 is none other than
vanessa the security guard the
assumption is that client 46 is
vanessa's other personality vani once
you listen to all 16 tapes it's pretty
clear that the therapists are talking to
two different personalities one that's
more mature also known as client 71 also
known as vanessa and one that's more
immature like a child also known as
client 46 and this makes sense until it
doesn't this is where things will get
debatable and a little confusing but
just hear me out client 71 and client 46
having two different therapist profiles
either proves that vanessa is actually
not fanny if vani is client 46 or that
client 46 is a different unknown
individual and here's why the only
people who could have created the
numbers for the clients would be their
physicians themselves the therapists
right i mean vanessa wouldn't refer to
herself as client 71 clearly the client
number system is something that's used
by the physicians in order to more
easily keep their patients in order this
is a very common practice in real life
and why would a psychotherapist use two
different client files for the same
client that's just unheard of so if
vanessa is client 71 and can't also be
46 then the question is who is client 46
well let's list everything we know about
them from their cd therapy sessions
first as many people point out client 46
is spoken to like a child the therapists
ask questions like you would to a child
they use terms that relate to children
like cubbyhole or time out which 46
finds funny and 46 likes to eat candy in
contrast to vanessa who not only doesn't
eat any when offered but knows the exact
number of calories in a single piece of
butterscotch candy now this could be the
therapist speaking to vanny who we
assume is child like since she's focused
on having fun with knives and skips
around which is clearly something only
children do
clearly also just wanted to cover this
mini theory real quick as some people
say that client 46 is vanessa but when
she's a child which could answer why
there are two different client files
this actually can't be the case since
the same therapists are shown talking to
both of them and get replaced by new
therapists at the same time for both of
the clients furthermore in cd14 the
therapist is speaking to client 46 and
talks directly about the freddy
fazbear's mega pizzaplex which is
obviously a very new establishment and
therefore proves that the therapy
session could not have taken place in
the early 2000s when vanessa would have
been a child since she was born in 1997.
anyway back to detailing what we know
about 46 they never speak at least not
what we can hear on tape which by the
way is pretty contrary to vani's
personality since she can do anything
but shut up normally which does a pretty
good job at aiding the scare factor in
security breach they are incredibly
talented with quote unusual skill like a
hacker the therapist then asks 46 if
they know what a hacker is again
implying that they might be a child who
doesn't appear to know what a hacker is
and even calls 46 a phenom which is
another word for a prodigy which is only
used to refer to unusually efficient
children moving on client 46 is never
once hinted at being employed by the
fazbear company and is even asked if
they know what the mega pizza plex is
that would be like asking a walmart
employee if they know what a super
walmart is of course an employee of the
company would know what the mega
pizzaplex is but the therapist assumes
that 46 might not know which is very
telling vanessa on the other hand is
constantly confirmed to be an employee
in nearly all of her cds with her
therapists asking her about encrypted
company emails and company break time
and even her transfer within phasma
entertainment when she moved to the
pizzaplex client 46 has a dark past
except they actually don't because they
lied to their therapists about their
childhood which is proven in the last cd
when the therapist confronts 46 directly
about their lies stating that 46
actually had a quote great childhood
[Music]
client 46 is also shown on camera
talking to vani and this is a very big
point by the way in cd15 the therapist
states that there is on camera footage
of 46 in the pizzaplex talking to quote
you're talking to someone
or something clearly the therapist is
referring to this someone or some thing
when talking about the rabbit ears and i
don't think it's bonnie since bonnie's
been gone from the pizzaplex for a while
and don't you think that fazbear
employees would recognize bonnie on the
tape or that the therapist would
recognize it as one of the robots bonnie
is one of the most famous of them now
given everything we just talked about
and trust me there is more but i digress
for the sake of time it appears to be
pretty obvious that 46 isn't vanessa
right but on the flip side let me play
devil's advocate for myself for a second
there are some pretty hard cases to
crack that would imply 46 is vanessa
such as the virus that is spread
throughout the pizzaplex's systems and
animatronics tracing back to not vanessa
but client 46. the event is talked about
in the later retro cds but also
referenced in the emails of five nets at
freddy's ar special delivery when there
is a virus spreading throughout the
fazbear systems which results in the
employees reaching out to fazbear tech
support to remove it it's implied pretty
heavily that the credentials given for
the tech representative v underscore a
stand for vanessa a after v underscore a
isolates the virus which gives the
employees a temporary boost of hope
itfaz employee lewis who clearly has a
crush on vanessa which is kind of cute
but kind of creepy emails her asking if
she happened to create an i.t department
email address for herself and use
company credentials to reach out to a
subcontractor and access their system
which again implies that the hacker is
vanessa because right after that all the
other employees lose admin access to the
system and eventually all access to
their computers as a whole that's when
all hell breaks loose and there's
another virus let in under the security
credentials underscore pizzaplex and all
of this seems pretty heavily to be the
hacking virus spreading event thing that
the therapist is confronting client 46
about insecurity breach hence the name
security breach
add this to the fact that vanessa is
shown in those ar emails to be
purchasing a fursuit and masks implying
she is creating the vani costume and the
fact that there is a vani hideout inside
of the mega pizzaplex with computer
access and you've got yourself a pretty
strong counter case for client 46
actually being vani the only reason why
it's debatable in addition to all the
proof about 46 not being vanessa i
already talked about is the fact that
vanessa is being manipulated on her
fazbear entertainment work computer
talking to someone else someone unknown
that she clearly tries to hide from the
therapists client 46 on the other hand
is sending manipulative messages to
someone who is inside the pizzaplex
there is also the fact that vanessa is
kind of naive and sloppy when doing all
this scary vanity suit stuff i mean her
search history is wide open for the it
team to use which lewis calls her out on
multiple times and would probably be
much more suspicious of her if he wasn't
in love with her if vanessa really were
the ultimate mastermind behind the virus
i just find it hard to believe she would
be careless enough to search dangerous
or revealing things on her company
computer given that she's supposed to be
this super intelligent phenom on the
other hand i could see her doing these
sorts of things if she were being told
what to do controlled influenced
manipulated by someone else that someone
being client 46 who would have told
vanessa to make the bunny suit and would
find that in music so honestly it could
work that client 46 is not vanessa but
is someone who could be a child prodigy
controlling vanessa the final question
that we have to circle back to is who is
client 46 then honestly i don't think we
have quite enough evidence to prove who
they are i mean hell at this point it
might even be a new character entirely
but just for the heck of it i'll throw
in this crazy weird only very slightly
believable theory
what if client 46 is gregory i know that
doesn't make much sense and i agree but
we are running out of living children in
this franchise to point our fingers at
and gregory is just weird okay in the
first place we don't even know that his
name is actually gregory i mean just
listen to how he tells freddie his name
i
i'm gregory after so confidently hiding
inside of frederie and scolding fragrant
freakery after so confidently hiding
inside of freddy and scolding freddy for
talking loudly gregory also doesn't have
a home or presumably any parents as
proven by the bad ending of the game and
is quite brilliant for a child being
able to pretty easily take down the
animatronics of the pizza plex without
freddie's help and even do things like
drive a car or use jumper cables to
charge freddy's battery in one of the
endings knowledge that a child doesn't
normally possess there's also the
blatant mystery of why gregory snuck
into the pizzaplex in the first place or
why he and vani seem to have some sort
of history she still comes looking for
him even when he escapes the pizzaplex
after 6am but that's really all the
quote-unquote evidence i have for
gregory being client 46. it doesn't
really make sense that gregory would be
client 46 and hack the systems or have
vanessa hack the systems and create vani
but then run away from vani for the
entirety of this game so i digress but
gregory is still probably the weirdest
part of this entire game and who knows
with the inevitable dlc we'll probably
get some more tasty bits of info and
hopefully we'll be able to more
accurately gauge just who this
mysterious client 46 is but for now i
think we can relatively safely say that
client 46 and client 71 are two separate
people not vanessa and vani unless vani
is for some reason not vanessa but she
probably is of course this is all just
my theory though what do you guys think
is clyde 46 an unknown manipulative evil
hacker genius child or are they just
vani the counterpart of vanessa who's
been manipulating herself the whole time
let me know in the comments below also
this is my first venture into the fnaf
theory realm so be nice to me would you
leave a like if you enjoyed the video or
at least my effort into the video and
subscribe to stick around for all sorts
of new theories on all sorts of games i
have more to talk about regarding
security breach as well including what i
think happened to glam rock bonnie so
let me know if you guys would like me to
make that video as always thank you so
much for watching and thank you to my
bandit crew for making these videos
possible if you'd like to help out check
out that join button below i think
that's about all for this one so i hope
you have a wonderful rest of your day
this is massington abandon looking
forward to seeing you next time and
signing out and stay away from
animatronics okay
[Music]
you